hi Conan O'Brien here today we make
history with our very first mobile
clueless gamer I'll be playing
Dragonball Legends I'm told this is a
massive deal I just don't know anything
about it so I enlisted a good friend Ron
Funches your Dragon Ball the game I love
the game I love the series I love the
lore yeah I could tell you all about ok
creepy the way you're sort of saying
well is it like raggedy ball how often
is you play dragon ball about an hour a
day and between my other games it's fine
they do is wait you take breaks from
other games to play this guess what
mobile games are good for so you play
this everywhere do you play this when
you're you know walking the street play
it on the streets I play it in the or I
play it on the toilet do mobile games on
the toilet yeah that's the whole point
of like having a job right now and then
you go to work you poop play mobile
games how well do you know all the
characters in Dragon Ball I know most of
them really yeah who's this guy that is
the main character that is Goku he's the
world's greatest fighter but not a great
dad because he always is either leaving
his kid to fight them for himself or
he's dead why is he dressed for an
actual flight it looks like he's just
completely dressed for comfort oh my god
it's a penis penis it went to the gym
what is it I mean dude then this is
spoiler alert but that's what mine looks
like
that's what might look like an 9 yet
even has that expression
disappointed German cuckoo clocks I
believe this is the Chief Justice as the
Supreme Court Chief Justice Roberts I
believe I can tell you what he's wearing
saying Armour but I don't feel like he
is a fan you know what can I say
something with the musculature they're
putting muscles in places where there
just aren't I don't think there's a
muscle there I'm working really good
lately up into a loss squads you do a
lot of squats yeah that's the piston
okay so I'm just looking at a leg that's
actually formed properly yeah I don't
have any musculature on my legs no no it
seemed like they would look like chicken
tenders there Ronnie what should explain
something to me there is something in
dragon ball where character you know
looks like they're summoning all this
crazy energy and then fire and light
comes out of their head we were
wondering if we could maybe get into
that state of super Sayan do you think
that's possible to become super saiyan
yeah do you think have you ever
experienced that before yes all it takes
is a lot of yelling you've got a lot of
focus a little bit of anger and you
could get there okay why don't you start
why don't you go there yeah you do it to
that Cameron you show me your super
Sayan
okay what am I thinking
you're thinking about maybe someone
punched your kid maybe so what one of my
kids has it coming not a good example
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I think we're ready to commence the
game and watch come on in
alright oh man awesome hey round house
so the first thing we need to do is kind
of open the game here so okay we're
gonna open the game here on a google
play alright and now we're gonna watch
this cinematic so cinematic means this
is the part they show us up front that
tells us the story yes
[Music]
Wow yes all right I'm gonna say
something that is amazing for years for
years I've been watching these video
games and they show a movie up front and
it's three hours of explanation this
told us nothing I'm dumber now than I
was when it started
get stuffed intelligence out of me and
it was exhilarating I loved it music
it's going through my head when I'm
having sex start off on chapter one here
but where am I
what was I doing I can't remember things
that's not a Japanese video game if you
don't have amnesia that's who they like
their amnesia don't they yeah Yamcha
that was great you just won you killed
everybody really quickly yeah yeah and
you were different characters at
different times which in it uh which
were you switching them on purpose yeah
oh you were doing that no I didn't know
you were doing that and if you want to
recharge your key just hold down on the
screen just analogous to anything in
life how do you recharge your key in
life
oh good massage just spend time with
friends okay I do you have time for
friends you say you play video games
constantly well online I talk to my
friends while we play games do you have
it's just the first time you've looked
someone in the eye in years yeah I don't
like this might be me know that you
don't like other humans raise your cool
all right so do you guys want to battle
each other now yeah yeah yeah there's a
lot of animosity between us long time oh
yes
suddenly who's the game RC o gonna hit
the rising rush hit the rising with
Hitler Ivan rocks I never win
[Applause]
not great there was a part of the game
where I thought it was ordering
something on Amazon I really good I
thought I was getting body soaps like I
feel like it would answering your phone
there was a time where I also thought I
was getting a call and instead I was
whipping your ass just incredibly so I
don't know if you want to do it super
sad what's that called when you blow up
you don't even know you don't even know
it's called no no you don't even know
that Sam Sam
yeah yeah whatever yeah when I did once
you do a super sad one right here I'll
get out of the way this is cool
Dragonball Legends is available now on
Google Play make sure you check it out
a team photo comes less clueless gamer
you